the legend will be born welcome to
planet arrakis the neville news dune is
one of the biggest films of 2021 and
quite a bit went into making it from
practical effects like moving platforms
and otherworldly sets it's amazing to
watch it director de nivel new didn't
want to rely on green screen and cg when
bringing the planet of arrakis to the
big screen villeneuve insisted that the
film be shot in the jordanian desert of
wadi rum which is known as the valley of
the moon they didn't shoot jaws in a
swimming pool villeneuve wanted to use
as many real environments as possible
and wanted the cast and crew behind the
film to be inspired by infinity what may
surprise fans is that according to
chalamet i think it's literally two
scenes i did on a green screen and uh
besides that everything else was
practical the filming conditions in the
jordanian desert of wadi rum weren't the
most preferable for the actors in front
of the cameras it gets so hot during the
day that sometimes you have to shoot
between 5am and 7am and 5pm and 7pm i
guess it'd be too dangerous to be
shooting outside filming also took place
in abu dhabi's liwa desert which was the
same desert that star wars the force
awakens filmed making it a bit of a
homecoming for oscar isaac the tents on
set had to be treated with air
conditioning as the movie was being
filmed on location in july and august
which are the hottest months of the year
in the liwa desert
i can't walk like regular humans the
team behind dune took a page from how
classical blockbusters were made when it
came to the film's practical effects
paul lambert the two-time oscar-winning
vfx supervisor behind dune revealed that
a four meter wide platform was made and
mounted on a system that allowed it to
vibrate at different speeds as soon as
that vibrating starts audiences will be
able to notice the actor's feet sinking
into the sand
when creating out-of-this-world vehicles
most films would either resort to cgi or
small-scale models that wasn't the case
when it came time to bring dunes iconic
thopters to life on the big screen the
thopters were made using gimbals on the
high hills of budapest the gimbals were
used so that the crew could raise lower
rotate and pivot the thopter on an axis
this would help make the thopter scenes
feel more real and even more intense for
audience members
they fight like demons an epic like dune
needs to have some intricate fight
scenes and denis villeneuve knew just
the guy to choreograph the fight scenes
roger yuan juan worked as a fight
coordinator for several major action
franchises such as the bourne films and
the james bond film skyfall with dune he
knew that each group of characters would
need their own fighting style for the
atreides joanne used more of a filipino
style of kali and escrima for the
sardakar yuan based the fighting moves
up for the ways of vikings and samurai
for the villainous and brutal harkenings
yuan decided to give them a more
beastial and sadistic fighting style
you fight when the necessity arises no
matter the mood while much of the
exterior shots of dune were filmed in
the jordanian desert of wadi rum for the
more detailed interiors real sets were
built inside studios in budapest one of
the main sets that was built in budapest
was the emperor's palace on arrakis the
sets were built as massive environments
and rooms so that their physical reality
could give the actors and actresses
ideas so they could each bring something
different into their performances the
massive size of the sets impressed even
oscar isaac it really made me feel like
i was in an alien planet from the ever
expansive architecture to the vast
desert and the larger-than-life ship the
physical sets were unlike anything most
of the cast had ever seen before
the visuals
the lighting
craig's unbelievable since dune takes
place on a different planet it'd be
strange if all the inhabitants just
spoke english which means that the team
behind the film would have to create a
new language the creative team members
contacted the king kongling david
peterson who worked on creating
languages for game of thrones to help
build languages for the film peterson
worked on four different linguistic
systems for dune two were spoken and two
were signed and also worked on an entire
writing system
this is doctor uh
the designs of the interiors of arrakis
were made to look as authentic as
possible in fact the crew behind the
film implemented cultural links from the
story into the carvings on the walls
this includes the sand worms which are
one of the most recognizable icons from
the dune lore one of the frescoes
showing off a carving of the sand worms
was made to look like it was carved by
the fremen working for the governor
greg fraser who served as the
cinematographer on the film found
himself in a bit of a challenge when
filming the interior scenes of the
arrakis compound the compound had no
windows as thematically it's supposed to
withstand war and heat production
designer patrice vermette and denis
villeneuve solved this by using light
wells throughout the fortress set the
light is effectively the byproduct of
bounce light that comes in through the
shaft it's not direct harsh sunlight
that's true like many other modern
blockbusters dune used the imax format
for entire sections of the film which
includes paul's vision as well as the
dream and desert sequences the rest of
the film was shot in the traditional 235
format which is used for most modern
movies in order to maintain the impact
and awe of the imax on the audience
villeneuve claimed that it was
beneficial to step away from time to
time villeneuve also made the decision
to film the desert scenes with a
handheld camera but the rest of the
world in the film would be more similar
to tableau
stellen skarsgard stars as dunes robust
villain baron harkin and claims that his
time in the makeup chair made up 30
percent of his entire time working on
the movie when it came time to film
baron's black murky bath the crew
debated about doing the scene digitally
skarsgard wasn't too bothered at that
point and didn't want to get out of his
intricate suit so he happily dipped
himself into that oh so unappealing bath
i got one surprise to fall color was
another major component that went into
making dune the neville nouve wanted
arakis to be harsh and desolate and an
environment that would be unwelcoming to
outsiders villeneuve along with the
cinematographer and production designers
tried their best to never make the sky
in the film look blue a lot of desert
photography was also done where there
was both yellow sand and a blue sky but
to avoid this the team veered away from
that and decided to make the sand look
more washed out and the sky more white
han zimmer is one of the most legendary
and influential composers in the
business zimmer had even turned down
working with christopher nolan so that
he could work on dune one of the most
interesting aspects of the dune score is
the use of bagpipes which according to
zimmer was completely denivel nouve's
idea after noticing a bagpiper in a
scene in the movie zimmer turned to
villeneuve who said well you can't just
do trumpets you can't do fanfare but
this ancient instrument could have been
around forever from there zimmer ended
up recruiting 30 different bagpipers to
make up for the unconventional addition
to the score production designer patrice
vermette had some unconventional ways of
finding locations to stand in for
arrakis in fact vermette used google
earth to scour the globe for potential
filming locations before settling on
wadi rum including iran chad mauritania
and libya vermette and villeneuve
selected wadi rum as they found it to be
like a trade show of rock formations
the pandemic caused some problems during
the post-production process of dune as
director denis villeneuve was unable to
work in the same room as his long-term
editor joe walker villeneuve claimed
that working separately was not the same
and that editing was much like playing
music you need to feel the other feel
his reaction feel your own reaction
there are so many ideas that joe and i
have i don't know if it's his idea or my
idea it comes from the addition of us
both being in the room which is by far
my favorite thing about cinema despite
dune being a passion project for denis
vlnew there have been plenty of other
attempts to bring frank herbert's novel
to the screen outside of the david lynch
movie from 1984 legendary filmmaker
alejandro yodorowski attempted to bring
it to life but to no avail years later
lone survivor filmmaker peter berg
attempted to bring the series to life
but was unsuccessful it wasn't until
denis villeneuve signed on to bring
frank herbert's vision to life that
things finally came together how dare
you use the voice on me from very
intricate details made with the sets
costumes and practical effects director
denis villeneuve and his team were
clearly passionate about making dune and
it truly shows on screen are you excited
to check out dune